good morning
when we announced the launch of the
klepto capture task force last month
i said we would leave no stone unturned
in our efforts to investigate arrest and
prosecute those whose criminal acts
enable russia to continue its unjust war
in ukraine
that is a promise we are keeping
i'm joined here today by deputy attorney
general monaco and fbi director ray
also here are assistant attorney general
olson principal deputy assistant
attorney general mcquade
fbi cyber section chief frim
and klepto capture task force director
adams
today we are announcing several actions
the justice department has taken to
disrupt and prosecute criminal activity
associated with the russian regime
the first action we are announcing today
is the unsealing of an indictment
charging russian oligarch constantine
malefev with sanctions violations
as indictment charges the treasury
department previously identified malefef
as one of the main sources of financing
for russians promoting separatism in
crimea
and for providing material support for
the so-called donetsk people's republic
after being sanctioned by the united
states
malafef attempted to evade the sanctions
by using co-conspirators to
surreptitiously acquire and run media
outlets across europe
we are also announcing the seizure of
millions of dollars from an account at a
u.s financial institution which the
indictment alleges constitutes proceeds
traceable to malafez sanctions
violations
the justice department will continue to
use all of its authorities to hold
accountable russian oligarchs and others
who seek to evade u.s sanctions
the second action we are announcing
today is the disruption of a global
botnet
controlled by the russian military
intelligence agency
commonly known as the gru the russian
government has recently used similar
infrastructure to attack ukrainian
targets
fortunately we were able to disrupt this
botnet before it could be used
thanks to our close work with
international partners we were able to
detect the infection of thousands of
network hardware devices
we are then able to disable the gru's
control over those devices
before the botnet could be weaponized
today's announcements are part of a
series of actions that the justice
department has recently taken to disrupt
and prosecute criminal activity
associated with russia
yesterday together with our german law
enforcement partners we seized the
russia-affiliated hydra darknet market
the world's largest illegal marketplace
on the dark web
we also filed criminal charges against a
russian national who we allege
administered the market's technical
infrastructure
and on the day before that
again with our international partners we
seized the tango
a super yacht owned by victor vexelberg
another sanctioned oligarch with close
ties to the russian regime
on that same day we obtained seizure
warrants targeting the assets of several
additional sanctioned russian nationals
the justice department will continue to
work alongside our international
partners
to hold accountable those who break our
laws
threaten our national security
and harm our allies
our message to those who continue to
enable the russian regime through their
criminal conduct
is this
it does not matter how far you sail your
yacht
it does not matter how well you conceal
your assets
it does not matter how cleverly you
write your malware
or hide your online activity
the justice department will use every
available tool to find you
disrupt your plots
and hold you accountable
finally
i cannot close without acknowledging the
horrible images
that all of us have seen coming out of
ukraine
particularly from bucha this week
we have seen the dead bodies of
civilians
some with bound hands
scattered in the streets
we have seen the mass graves
we have seen the bombed hospital
theater
and residential apartment buildings
the world sees what is happening in
ukraine
the justice department sees what is
happening in ukraine
this department has a long history of
helping to hold accountable those who
perpetrate war crimes
one of my predecessors attorney general
robert jackson later served as the chief
american prosecutor at the nuremberg
trials
today
we are assisting international efforts
to identify and hold accountable those
responsible for atrocities in ukraine
and we will continue to do so
i'm now going to turn over the program
to deputy attorney general monaco who
will share more information about the
indictment that was unsealed today
thank you mr attorney general and good
morning everyone thank you all for
joining us today
as the attorney general said we are here
today because of actions the department
of justice has taken today and in recent
weeks
actions that make clear that the same
russian government struggling to defend
its unprovoked and unjustified war
in the ukraine is also
corrupt at its core
the world has watched with outrage as
innocent ukrainians continue to suffer
at the hands of the russian government
and for decades the regime has been
propped up by pervasive corruption
the corruption starts at the top
with vladimir putin's oligarch cronies
who earned billions of dollars by
committing crimes often at the expense
of the russian people
the crimes these billionaires facilitate
in fact facilitate
russia's unprovoked aggression and fuel
a life of luxury for the very few
the world watches in horror as
ukrainians are forced to flee their
homes
schools and hospitals and as they bury
innocent civilians
last month the attorney general asked me
to establish a task force task force
klepto capture
to use the full range of the
department's authorities to hold
accountable those oligarchs who enable
the russian regime and to ensure that
those same oligarchs feel the pain of
the sanctions that have been levied on
them in response to russia's aggression
in ukraine
that task force has been hard at work
earlier this week
our law enforcement partners in spain
acting on our request and pursuant to a
warrant issued by a united states court
seized a 90 million dollar yacht named
the tango
belonging to sanctioned russian oligarch
victor vexelberg
that yacht was subsequently searched by
spanish authorities accompanied by
agents of the fbi and homeland security
investigations
vekselberg was sanctioned in 2018 by the
u.s treasury department as part of a
suite of sanctions imposed in response
to russia's invasion of crimea
mr vekselberg defied these sanctions to
finance his luxury lifestyle
including making payments through u.s
banks for the support and maintenance of
his yacht a direct violation of the
sanctions imposed on him
in seizing the tango the department
demonstrated our commitment to holding
accountable corrupt russian oligarchs a
commitment we are not finished honoring
today
charges have also been unsealed in the
southern district of new york against
constantine malafeth a russian national
and a russian oligarch malafev is
charged with conspiring to violate and
violating united states sanctions
these are the first criminal charges
brought by the department of justice
against a russian oligarch since russia
invaded ukraine
mr malafev was designated as a result of
the crimea sanctions which forbade him
from conducting financial transactions
with united states persons or with
property in the united states
in the year since he was sanctioned mr
malefev is alleged to have flagrantly
and repeatedly
violated the sanctions imposed on him
while attempting to establish media
companies across europe media companies
that would help spread pro-kremlin
misinformation
mr malefev further violated u.s
sanctions in a scheme to transfer shares
he owned in a texas bank to a business
associate in two thousand fifteen
today
in addition to the criminal charges
filed
against mr malefev we have seized that
multi-million dollar investment
while the oligarchs provide some of the
most ostentatious displays of russian
illicit finance they are not the only
ones whose financial misconduct is tied
to russia
yesterday the department of justice
disrupted the hydra market the world's
largest and longest running darknet
marketplace
at the same time the department of
justice brought criminal charges against
dmitry pavlov a resident of russia for
his role in operating and administering
the servers used
to run hydra
our partners at the german federal
criminal police played a critical role
in this operation and seized over 25
million dollars in bitcoin from hydra
and our partners at the treasury
department announced sanctions on the
cryptocurrency
is believed to have facilitated many of
hydra's transactions
as alleged hydra enabled users in mainly
russian-speaking countries to buy and
sell a staggering variety of illicit
goods and services including
illegal drugs stolen financial
information fraudulent passports and
even hacking tools and hacking services
transactions on hydra were conducted in
cryptocurrency and last year hydra alone
accounted for an estimated eighty
percent of all dark net market related
cryptocurrency transactions since 2015
the marketplace has received
approximately 5.2 billion dollars in
cryptocurrency
let me say that again
hydra alone
accounted for an estimated 80 percent of
all dark net market transactions more
than five billion dollars in
cryptocurrency
working side by side with our german
partners whose assistance was critical
to our efforts as well as our law
enforcement partners at the irs and the
u.s postal inspection service here at
home
the dea and the fbi have ensured that
cryptocurrency can no longer be used by
these criminals to fuel their crimes
taken together these actions make clear
that those who violate our laws should
expect to face justice
as russia
and its aggression continues
we have our eyes on every yacht and jet
we have our eyes on every piece of art
and real estate
purchased with dirty money
and on every bitcoin wallet filled with
proceeds of theft and other crimes
together with our partners around the
world our goal is to ensure that
sanctioned russian oligarchs and cyber
criminals will not find safe haven
and now i'll turn it over to director
ray to discuss another tool employed by
the fbi
to address russia's aggression
thank you lisa i'm pleased to be here
today to help announce this series of
actions countering threats originating
from russia
want to focus for a few minutes on the
fbi's role in one of the actions the
attorney general mentioned and what it
says
about the fbi's unique cyber
capabilities and what we can accomplish
together with the private sector today
we're announcing a sophisticated court
authorized operation disrupting a botnet
of thousands of devices controlled by
the russian government before
it could do any harm
we removed malware from devices used by
thousands of mostly small businesses for
network security
all over the world and then we shut the
door the russians had used to get into
them
yesterday's darknet takedown struck a
blow against russian criminals and the
ecosystem of cryptocurrency tumblers
money launderers malware purveyors and
others
supporting them
the botnet disruption we're announcing
today strikes a blow against russian
intelligence
the russian government
the bot network we disrupted was built
by the gru the russians government's
military intelligence agency and in
particular it was the unit in the gru
known to security researchers as sand
worm team
this gru team sandworm had implanted a
specific type of malware known as
cyclops blink
on thousands of watchguard technologies
firebox devices these are security
appliances mainly firewalls that are
typically deployed in home office
environments and in small to mid-sized
businesses
sanworm
strung them together to use their
computing power in a way that would
obfuscate who was really running the
network to let them then launch malware
or to orchestrate distributed denial of
service attacks like
the gru has already used to attack
ukraine
i should note here
that the gru's sandworm team has a long
history of outrageous destructive
attacks the disruption
of the ukrainian electric grid in 2015
attacks against the winter olympics and
the paralympics in 2018
a series of disruptive attacks against
the nation of georgia in 2019 and
in 2017 the not petya attack that
devastated ukraine but also ended up
hitting systems here in the u.s
throughout europe and elsewhere
causing more than 10 billion dollars
that's with a b
in damages one of the most damaging
cyber attacks in the history
of cyber attacks
with the court authorized operations
we're announcing today we've disrupted
this botnet before
it could be used we were largely able to
do that because we had close cooperation
with watchguard we've worked closely
with watchguard to analyze the malware
and develop detection tools and
remediation techniques over the past
several weeks
and our operation removed russia's
ability to control
these firebox devices on the botnet
network and then copied and removed
malware
from the infected devices
i should caution that as we move forward
any firebox devices that acted as bots
may still remain vulnerable in the
future until mitigated by their owners
so those owners should still go ahead
and adopt
watchguard's recommended detection
and remediation steps as soon as
possible
we're continuing to conduct a thorough
and methodical investigation but as
we've shown we are not going to wait for
our investigations to end
to act
we're going to act as soon as we can
with whatever partners are best situated
to help
to protect the public
this announcement today shows the value
of the fbi's technical expertise and
unique authorities both as a law
enforcement agency and
an intelligence service
that unique combination both of which
were essential
to the success of this operation
it also shows what we can accomplish
with our partners
to help companies like the thousands of
mostly small businesses affected by this
botnet hit by threats like these posed
by the russian government
our partnership with the private sector
was key here watchguard enthusiastically
cooperated with the fbi to figure out
the source of the infection
and to counter it
that kind of cooperation makes successes
like the one we're announcing today
possible
and it'll continue to be important going
forward
the russian government has shown that it
has no qualms about conducting this kind
of criminal activity and they continue
to pose an imminent threat
and this
global botnet disruption
in conjunction with the other actions
discussed today reflect an aggressive
effort by the fbi and our partners to go
on offense against russian cyber threats
wherever
they appear
i'd also like to commend our partners at
the dea irs and our foreign partners on
the hydra darknet takedown
and all the men and women of the fbi
involved with both of those operations
as well as the indictments
and property seizures involving russian
oligarchs this week
i should emphasize that we will continue
to rely on companies to work with us the
way watchguard has so that we can
protect
our nation's cybersecurity together
for businesses
i would encourage you to have a cyber
security plan and to include contacting
your local fbi field office
as an important part of that plan
and if you suspect a cyber intrusion
please contact your local fbi field
office immediately
the more quickly we get involved the
more we can do
to protect you
we are laser focused on disrupting the
threat on preventing
harm from dangerous adversaries
and sometimes that means making arrests
and other times like both yesterday and
today that means taking adversaries
capabilities
off the field
no agency
or business can do this alone it takes
everyone's cooperation and the fbi will
be there to work with you on cyber
threats from russia
or anywhere else
finally i would like to thank and
congratulate our fbi teams
in a wide number of field offices both
here in the united states
and our legal attache offices overseas
for their work that has paid off this
week
with seizing sanctioned assets here and
in spain
with the indictments that we're
announcing today
and with the disruption of both criminal
and hostile intelligence activities that
we're here to discuss
this morning
thank you
mr attorney general you said the justice
department has a long history of holding
those accountable who commit war crimes
what
role for the justice department do you
contemplate in ukraine
yesterday i personally spoke with our
chief
justice department prosecutor in paris
who was meeting with the french
war crimes prosecutor
the day before criminal division
prosecutors met with prosecutors from
euro just and europol
to
work out a plan for gathering evidence
with respect to ukraine
and at the same time the united states
is at the request of the ukrainian
prosecutor assisting in the collection
of
information with respect to the
atrocities that took place
in ukraine and that are still taking
place
all right
uh mr attorney general are you calling
for a nuremberg style trial and would
you be involved in that number one on on
an off topic question
i know that you don't comment on ongoing
investigations but would you confirm
that you're being briefed on the hunter
biden investigation
all right on the
second off topic question
we don't comment about pending
investigations so that's as best i can
give you on that
on the former i'm not calling for
anything at this time right now we're in
the collection of evidence stage and
that's what we're doing we're helping
our european partners and our ukrainian
partners
uh and our partners across the united
states government including the
particularly the
department of state to collect the
information on the atrocities that we
have all seen
in both photographs and video footage of
this week
can't help but
pain every one of us to watch that
but that's what we will be doing
collecting that information for purposes
of investigation
the announcement today is about
sanctions dating back to actions that
happened in 2014 does the justice
department need to move faster
to make these sanctions matter in what's
happening in ukraine today do you need
or want more authority in some fashion
to move faster on sanctions
well i hope you were going to conclude
that we were moving awfully fast given
the number of things that we've
announced today and we announced before
when once sanctions are imposed
then the violation you know that that
freezes
then the violation of sanctions is
attempting to move them attempting to
hide them attempting to distribute them
so of course we're moving on the ones
that have violated the sanctions rules
but we also have sanctions that the
treasury department has imposed and
anyone who attempts to violate those
sanctions will be prosecuted
investigated
there will be seizures as soon as we as
soon as we can chris
uh mr attorney general i'm wondering how
much you're seeing evasive activity by
russian oligarchs that you're that
you're targeting at this point
are they taking um your specific steps
what kind of specific steps are we
taking to hide their assets and then
if i may um let me find that one first
um so i'm going to turn to the deputy
attorney general and
the director of the task force to answer
that question thanks very much well as
the attorney general um mentioned the
sanctions activity
once those are imposed that freezes the
assets and the criminal activity is in
itself the evading of those sanctions so
seeking to move those assets now i'm not
going to disclose to you what we see in
our investigations uh but suffice to say
that we have sophisticated methods and a
great deal of expertise that we've
brought together with the kleptocapture
task force whether it's money uh
laundering tracing sophisticated
cryptocurrency
tracing efforts
you name it we're bringing all of that
to bear
to go after the efforts to evade these
sanctions using whatever means
criminal actors use i'll ask
mr adams if you've got anything to add
thank you i think as as the indictments
themselves lay out the the department's
aware of a number of different
typologies and processes by which people
attempt to hide assets there are
obviously public reporting
and
and
very much public online twitter feeds
regarding the physical movement of
ostentatious property that i think
everybody is aware of the department's
aware of those and other efforts and
we'll continue to investigate invasion
in all forms
on the um
you mentioned that you're helping uh to
document the war crimes that are taking
place um in you that you're uh that
you're helping uh your international
partners can you be more specific on how
you're helping them what specifically
are you doing well i think i've i think
i've told all i can tell right now we've
been meeting uh with europol and
eurojust in
paris over this week
and as i said our chief our most senior
justice department criminal division
prosecutor has been meeting with the
french prosecutor
war crimes prosecutor and we're working
with the state department team on a
multinational um effort uh to support
the ukrainian prosecutor
mr attorney general can you uh first
identify the media organizations that
you believe are
linked to the oligarch and then i have a
second question
i don't know whether that was disclosed
in the indictment but i'll leave it
there the specific names are not
disclosed in the indictment mr malofia
of is is obviously a public
personality and
we'll find uh find plenty of information
of them on open source
then if i may it's been several weeks
since the department received a referral
from congress on mark meadows and the
house is poised to vote again on two
referrals today what do you say to those
who may be losing confidence in the
department because it's taking so long
and do you have concerns that
congressional referrals become somewhat
toothless if the department doesn't take
enforcement action yeah so the meadows
referral went to the united states
attorney for the district of columbia
it's been made quite public and we will
follow the facts in the law wherever
they lead uh we don't comment any
further on uh
investigations thanks all right thank
you everybody thank you